il est très attaché rien il est libéral
économiquement et conservateurs
socialement c'est vraiment ce qui le
caractérise le plus possible je rappelle
quand même le bilan madame thatcher
toute la dérégulation notamment dans les
transports ferroviaires françois fillon
il veut baisser l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les familles aisées
nous ne baissons pour 12 millions de
foyers fiscaux pour les familles
classement classe moyenne il veut
supprimer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
on voit quand même ça qu'il est très
libéral il veut augmenter la tva rendez
vous compte de 2%
vous rendez compte ça veut dire que le
simple de deux points ça veut dire que
tous les français lorsqu'ils vont
acheter leurs produits de première
nécessité vont être impactés par une
augmentation
nous nous sommes refusés à le à le faire
on a parlé des fonctionnaires s'ils
étaient on attendait on a parlé de la
tva sociale nous pensons nous que c'est
une que par erreur baisse les
cotisations que c'est une erreur
et puis sur l'aspect international il
aura à répondre des questions et sur la
société sur la famille j'ai compris
d'ailleurs depuis ce matin et a entendu
monsieur raffarin et entendu monsieur
juppé lui-même que dans le débat et dans
les meetings on va avoir des questions
sur la famille sur les questions
sociétales et sur l'international
puisque sur l'international ça peut être
un renversement d'alliance et un
changement de pied par rapport notamment
à la russie de monsieur poutine
et là il faudra qu'il s'explique